I heard that the Ground Self-Defense Force is researching magic lines,
but you're also attending high
school.
As
soon as I said that I had to quit the Self-Defense Forces, it went right
I'm half-joking, but I
thought maybe I was like a stalker
No, I was just a little surprised The
situation hasn't changed about the last Halloween
, but
I don't care anymore  The
enemy doesn't think so.It's better for us to be
NEETs as much as possible.If possible, it's better
to live in the same
house.Cleaning.The transfer students get along
well.I'm Makino
Nozomi.  ken a Yes,
I'm Asuka's best friend, aren't I?
Hey, what kind of person is Asukayama to Kurumi Village?
Not only is she kind, but she's also strong-minded.